all right Joey yes sir Joey uh where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally Martinez California Home in
the martini actually where's that up
north uh yeah um it's east of Oakland uh
about 30 minutes 45 out of San Francisco
45 out of Sacramento tell me about your
family growing up well I was an AA baby
uh my mom and my uh dad both met in the
Glorious rooms of Alcoholics and anous
um I uh was the uh last of four children
uh the only uh uh child of that marriage
um my mom stayed sober my dad didn't so
there was a lot of um a lot of uh drug
use in the home there was a lot of uh
you know a lot of violence a lot of of
uh things getting thrown uh you know
cops ninjas in the basement um you know
according to my dad or um you know we'
go to the grocery store we come back and
all the walls would be taken out and
there'd be wires everywhere cuz there
was meth in the walls um according to
him he actually bought a house once
because he was certain that there was
meth in the uh in the
frame um so yeah you know uh I kind of
grew up um very much against all of that
and I was um we were also a very like uh
uh God-fearing home um you know and uh
big
churchgoers uh which was uh two some
pretty pretty conflicting ideologies you
know of the drug addiction in the in the
in the church stuff but um you know one
of the constant through that was music I
I grew up um wanting to you know
learning how to play music and and
playing um a pretty high high Cali
caliber pretty early
on um
I uh really didn't start getting into
using myself until I was about 15 or 16
years old smoking weed you know taking
ader
all um and uh everything kind of changed
uh halfway through my junior year I
moved to public school and and um I had
a script to Adder all so I was like hey
what's up private school kid here's some
[__] weed so uh you know started
doing that pretty uh pretty um uh pretty
regularly and that was the one thing
that my my at this point my dad was out
out of the house was my mom and my
stepdad um you know weed's pretty easy
to smell so
um uh you know I got put an outpatient
pretty early on uh started drinking
really heavily by myself which kind of
progressed um you know uh halfway
through or like um the summer between my
my Junior and Senior year I went to my
first inpatient Treatment Center um for
alcohol and
Aderall and uh 17 I I moved out of the
house I was in sober living in the in in
um in Santa Cruz um and I
found uh over the counter cough
medication known as dextrorphan or
robotussin robot
tripping uh and uh at this point um you
know I finally had found
something that um
was very similar to the the dissociation
that I used to do when I was uh you know
when I was in therapy and stuff from
some of the the earlier trauma um that I
went through uh and and it was like I
found a switch I found a switch to take
me out
of um the person that that that I was
and and could take me somewhere
somewhere else and I wanted it at all
cost um you know it wasn't necessarily
the most um the most orthodox of drugs
but you know I I did it every day I
stole it from the store and and um you
know I I I took it until the wheels fell
off um and then you know it was around
uh 19 I I was in a treatment center and
they called me the cough syrup kid what
does what does robotussin do for you uh
it's so it's a dissociate of
hallucinogen in the same category is
like ketamine and
PCP so um for me it had had this kind of
upper feeling to it but also dumbed my
mind down enough for me to um process uh
things on uh what seemed like the the
normal level that everybody else around
me was was um was kind of going on and
it was um you know it was just a way for
me to like uh to
to understand my surroundings but also
to numb out a lot of that trauma that I
was talking about earlier
on um the the trauma you went through as
a kid was mainly what yeah uh so my my
dad was extremely physically violent um
he uh one day uh you know my mom and I
were sitting at the
table um we my mom had finished her her
chores or whatever and and I was four
and we were doing a puzzle together and
um my dad came in started screaming at
my mom for not being in uh not not
working not doing what he thought she
should be doing and he uh threw a um
sectional couch out of both um I mean
and it was just
really
um you know it there there there when he
got to that point it was there was so
much collateral damage it didn't really
matter didn't matter who was in the way
that rage and that anger was going to be
realized uh so a lot of that a lot lot
of physical beatings um spent a lot of
time hiding under my bed as a kid um
hiding from from his abuse and and um uh
um you know uh I think a lot of that um
was where a lot of his addiction came
from was was his upbringing and and and
his VI the the violence in his past just
kind of being perpetuated um from
generation to generation
um so yeah you know I just continued to
um delve deeper into this this kind of
fantasy world until um you know uh I had
gotten made fun of a lot for being the
cough syrup kid and for uh you know why
don't you go why why don't you go out
and [__] do some real drugs you know
why don't why don't you get high like a
like like how much cser how much robot
tesin would you I was um anywhere from
not a spoonful I take it oh no no uh I I
was taking boxes of the U the the cough
suppressant cor seeden so uh 16 pills in
a box I was taking anywhere from uh two
to six boxes a day um and at most three
at a time that's a lot of cougher yeah
um a lot of a lot of hospital visits a
lot of people don't really know what to
know what to do when one eye is going
this side one eye is going that way and
you can't walk people have uh
people you know they don't really know
how to respond to that so a lot of like
I said a lot of er visits a lot of um in
and out of the hospital and um it was
also really difficult to treat because
um it was everywhere you know it wasn't
just like with alcohol where you could
buy it anywhere it was so easily
accessible to steal and not have to pay
for you know it's um I mean can you
imagine if if meth meth or heroin were
just accessible in in in any given store
like that's how much I liked this [__]
um and uh so you know I was I was doing
a lot of that and um until uh you know I
I decided that uh I was going to smoke
some math and um I I actually had left a
um I I went through a Scientology
treatment center on accident at um 18
my parents thought that they were
getting in me getting me into like a a
like a um like a holistic like health
and wellness type uh treatment center
and then I get there and I look around
and every book on the wall is written
and based on the works of Elon hubard
and I'm just like oh my God where the
[__] am I um mind you they also made me
uh spend uh all of my um my uh my my
college savings on this on this program
too so um I left um and
uh uh met this guy named Phil outside of
the uh Rescue Mission in in
Sacramento and um he asked me if I'd
ever done Chris before and uh of course
I'm like uh yeah uh no I never have but
I've always wanted to um what I did not
understand was some of the uh the
connotations of a an an older man who
has just spent years in prison what his
um what
his what what
um the uh intentions were uh with a
19-year-old
kid
um so that turned into a really dark
scary situation very very fast um he
kept me he held me
captive um for somewhere around 15 to 16
hours at knife point in his house uh his
mom's house actually um you his sexual
slave pretty much yeah yeah yeah um and
of course I had I had no
idea um what I got myself into you know
there's this this big ass dude with a
black knife [__]
you know I had to come up with a uh
solution to get out of that situation I
finally convinced them to
leave the the house so that we can go to
a a
motel and uh
so I book I bounce I took I I take off I
get I jump into a um into a
uh
uh believe it was a it was a Taco Bell
get in the Taco Bell bathroom
5: in the morning and I'm like who Who
Am I who could I possibly call in this
situation so I called my
dad um at this time I uh it turned out
that my dad had about um a year and in
some change uh sober at the time and
um uh I was like dad someone's coming to
kill me and um I'm in this McDonald at
or this Taco Bell on McDonald in uh
Sacramento and he need you to come pick
me up he's like you are you paranoid
right now I like I don't think so but
there is a very good possibility I might
be and so uh he comes and he picks me up
and and um he goes to take me to to to
detox and and um we get to a uh we get
to l a literal Crossroads you know this
way is the premiere in in conquered and
then this way was was detox pbl St
soul and he looks at me and he says you
want to get do you want to get another
bag and um I think he's [__] with me
I you know I'm like here's this guy uh
18 months clean [__] with me um I was
like you know what no why don't you just
just take me take me to
detox so I didn't find out for um couple
days then couple days goes by and my dad
tells his story at that treatment
center and he was he told me I was dead
serious he like I was dead serious you
know and we were that it it become it
had gotten that close to you know me
taking my dad
out
um and we never ended up using together
but um you know years and years just
continued to go on I was in and out of
treatment centers um I have been in
upwards including detox outpatient sober
living
inpatient
um around 87 times um I've just been
continuously in and out in and out as
recent as Monday um I uh had 90 days
clean um went down to the um went down
to the the gr office and it was
indigenous people's day [__] news to
me and um so this girl sits comes s sits
down next to super hot you know and I
thought she was like some Mom working
out at the gym right down the street
she's like don't I know you from
somewhere and I was like like from where
she's like oh don't want to know you
from downtown this was all the way out
in [__] uh on Olympic in Hower like
around that that area and I was like uh
I don't think so she's like yeah we
smoke fentanyl together she's like you
want to smoke some
fentanyl you know I'm good I'm good
right now like I got to go back to my
sober living I just got a phone she like
oh you're in sober living so you want to
smoke some Fetti with me like [__] and
and and she must have asked me four or
five times and I finally came in
man but um you
know uh
um this kind of brings me
to a year ago let's just say a year ago
um I it was actually in November
um I checked in for yet another
detox and uh I checked my um I checked
my my
uh my Facebook on somebody else's um
phone and I got a message and and the
message said
um please contact Jesse Ruiz Jesse Ruiz
is my grandfather I thought it said
Joseph Ruiz and who was my my father my
father has the same name I was like hey
I'm you know last time we spoke I really
wasn't very happy with the things that
he said um let him know that I'll give
him a call back
soon and she said I'm sorry to tell you
this your father is has passed away um
turns out my my um
dad died from an
overdose um in the end of October of
last year
so this last year has been really really
really difficult um
but I you know the one thing I will say
is that I'll never stop giving up or
that that that I'll never give up hope
and that I'll never stop fighting fting
that there's this a it's a Latin saying
and um it's uh or yeah it's either Greek
or Latin it says uh DPO D Spyro which
literally means I breathe I hope and
it's like
wherever there is breath there is hope
and that's what I hope people can
remember from my
story what do you think the reason is
that you you're unsuccessful over and
over again with the with the rehab
attempts
um cuz it's not my time yet to you know
but is it is it is it purely just a Dr a
drug addiction or is it something to do
with selfworth and feeling like you
don't deserve it yet I think that that
absolutely has a huge part to do to do
with it you know I think that selfworth
I think that um you know it's not just
the substance that I'm that I'm uh that
I'm struggling with it's it's a whole
way of life it's a whole um it's a
whole there's something about the person
that I am that makes it a lot
easier to put a needle in my arm than to
go out and fill out a [__] job
interview um so yeah you know I think
that there is a lot of of um different
aspects to it
but I'm not going to keep giving I'm I'm
not going to keep
fighting and I'm never going to give up
hope your drug now is f me meth and
fentel meth and
fentel how are you making
money um fence gr food stamps
prescriptions um whatever
whatever where you staying uh here on SK
out and about in a tent or uh no no
chrst Matthew don't sleep oh no no I
just don't sleep and when I do it's
usually in a hospital or my body is just
so beat at this point how many days have
you been up um well I slept a couple
hours
yesterday so but I mean I had been up
since Monday and I'll probably be up
again until Monday so like you're
sleeping once a week yeah usually
yeah do you have any regrets in your
life
H I regret what I said to my
dad the last thing I said to him was um
stop making this about you you
narcissistic
[__] and that was in August and he died
in
October I regret that not much else
though are you going to walk in your
dad's footsteps no
no and not because of a um sense of
Pride but out
of how
devastated I am because of it and how
much more devastating it would be to the
people in my life because we are a lot
closer than I was to him how old do you
know 29 you have kids no thank
God
someday once I've put all this behind
me what's your greatest fear
Joey uh oh life
wasted it's good
fear what would you say what would you
say is the most important lesson you've
learned in your life the meaning of life
is to give your life
meaning then in those darkest
moments or when we
choose the
story that we live and the and the the
the person that we
become is solely dicta upon who we
decide to
become it's all within our own
power you got a great head on your
shoulders hope hope it
stays good luck man thank you very much
thank
you